It's so good just for one week,
one week was really all the time that
was needed for this man.
The president of the United States stab
his first diplomatic crisis.
So who was this crisis with?
Well,
you can probably guess the answer is
Mexico.
Mexico is the new China.
Mexico is killing us.
The country of Mexico is killing us.
Donald trump is well,
let's say unique.
He might be the only head of state
capable of defying in public a foreign
presidents in this case.
That's opinion.
Yet though,
like telling him on twitter if doesn't
travel to Washington with the idea of
paying for the wall,
he may as well stay at home.
Needless to say,
the visit never happens.
Live Travis Mikiko,
but don't worry.
View as we've had enough trump talk to
the donald is not going to be the main
character in this video.
Today we're going to focus on the Nafta
agreement and especially on the
relationship between Mexico and the
United States of America.
Laughter is a free trade agreements
between the US,
Canada,
and Mexico.
It was negotiated by President George H,
w Bush in 1992,
and it was ratified and implemented by
Bill Clinton in 1995.
Hey,
Nafta has been supported both by
Democrats and the Republicans,
but let's take a look back and analyze
which events took place.
South of the Bravo Riverton.
Yeah,
let's travel back and tell him to the 19
eighties.
It's telling.
When Mexico was exhausted,
the country's economic model was a worn
out closed economy and they were in a
state of crisis.
In fact,
it was a dance hall.
Him with a massive immigration from
Mexico to the US started to happen and
it wasn't just any migratory wave.
It was one of the biggest migration
waves of all time
and all of this happens in a time when
Americans weren't particularly liked in
Mexico since the war with the US from
easy 46 to 18,
48 when Mexico lost more than half of
its territory.
The popular sentiment in the country was
that the US was a great villain and an
enemy that Mexico was facing by 1988.
It was clear that Mexico is closed.
System was worn out and the president of
Mexico,
who at the time was Carlos Salinas,
a Harvard graduate by the way,
decided to end this and opted for
opening up Mexico to the outside world
in his own words,
the US is not the worst threat that have
the best opportunity and the leaders in
North America decided they didn't want
to waste this chops.
They got down to business and decided to
bet on extending to Mexico a free trade
agreements that they had recently signed
with Canada with this.
Nafta was born.
Since then,
relations between the U S and have
expanded a great deal.
It is estimated the trade between the
two countries today exceeds half
$8,000,000,000,000.
Now a half a trillion,
which is $500.
Million dollars is quite a hard number
to get your head around in more
relatable terms each minute.
So that means more than a million
dollars worth of products crosses the
border of the U,
s and Mexico,
or to put it in a more international
context,
trade between the US and Mexico is the
equivalence of the Chilean economy and
does more than the entire economy of
Argentina.
The Gardens,
American President,
Donald Trump threatens this agreement.
Sam does even considered putting an end
to it because according to him,
it is the worst agreements that the US
has ever signed.
Nafta is the worst trade deal ever
signed anywhere,
but certainly ever signed in this
country.
Now that's just what he says and the
reality.
Well,
bits rob.
The difference after has in general been
something of a goldmine for the United
States.
It has been said that whenever trump has
a nightmare,
it's always the same thing he sees and
Mexicans stealing.
Here's what your company anyway,
we don't know if this is true bits,
probably nice,
but it would explain his obsession with
Mexico and also why whenever he thinks
of Nafta,
he thinks of the American people getting
robbed,
but zone thing that it is only the
president you holds in his opinion,
they need defenders of protectionism.
In the US stated that Mexican and
Canadian workers are causing American
jobs to disappear because of free trade.
Specifically,
they claimed that imports exceed exports
by almost $80,
billion dollars,
and that's a lot of money,
but the reality is that these figures
are about as reliable as a chocolate
teapot.
First,
there are two goods that twists those
numbers which have nothing to do with
Nafta,
petrol and natural gas.
And this is really important because if
we don't consider those products that
treat all that trump is talking about
pretty much disappears.
Now,
some of you are probably thinking,
well,
Simon,
why wouldn't you consider petrol and
natural gas?
And that's a good question.
Well,
that's because unless trump wants to
take the United States back to the Stone
Age,
he will have to keep getting all the
petrol the country needs,
whether that's from Mexico,
Canada,
Saudi Arabia,
Orwell,
well anywhere else,
but these budget figures aren't the only
ones.
The protection is dreamers also fudged
the biggest for.
They also do this by not considering
service businesses.
This includes things like the financial
sector,
the insurance sector,
traveling,
consulting,
the Internet,
etc. And etc. Etc.
But ignoring these things is like sAying
the banks don't make money and the
google simply doesn't exist.
So if we adjust these two figures,
it turns out that the us' results is not
a deficit,
but it's actually a surplus that's true
for both Mexico runs,
whether it's Canada,
it's actually a surplus of more than $40
billion
donuts.
The americans are really the ones who
are making off like bandits in this
trade relationship.
All right,
but in mExico it's a bit different
because even correcting the numbers,
the us still gets the deficits in this
relationship.
So the question is,
what is the actual number?
Well,
waiver,
it's approximately in drum roll.
Please zero point five percent of its
gdp.
Yes.
I'm sorry to disappoint you.
It is really that missile.
In fact,
the deficit is actually smaller than the
one they have with China,
Japan or Germany.
Almost all american industries export to
Mexico more than the emBossed with the
exception of autism.
You can guess where the profits are
going to end up,
but there is more.
It is said that the main reason for the
company's moving that factories to
Mexico is because the wages are lower,
but that's only half the truth and
certainly isn't the main reason.
What's interesting about Mexico for car
companies is that Mexico has many more
free trade agreements with other
countries than the us does and this
allows them to produce and sell their
cars in other markets like Brazil and
the european union without terrorists,
which saves them a lot of money.
About $700,000,000 a year.
Yeah.
The benefits of these operations getting
to end dump.
Yes.
Once again,
back in the pockets of the United States
of America,
john salon cabins with casinos.
The house always wins,
so thanks to Mexico.
Car companies in the usa are more
competitive and to have more profits.
Well,
consumers in America combine much
cheaper.
All of this,
americans have more money to go to the
senator,
to buy clothes,
to change their small phones more often
and take part in all that consumer
spending that we all love so much.
This all makes the economic wheels spin
them faster.
Boss
now probably seems to you,
yeah,
Mexico is actually pretty important to
the usa,
but imagine the other way round.
Almost 80 percent of mexican exports
ends up in northern neighbor,
so it's no surprise that the threat of
the ends of nafta has reminded many of
the famous quotes attributed to
porfirio,
diaz,
Mexico.
It's so far from god and so near the
usa.
Nafta has been incredibly positive than
Mexico.
As a quick example,
do you know which is the biggest
employer in Mexico?
Well,
that's
unfortunately really
this huge investment by us companies
hasn't actually given the growth that
was expected and for the reason for
that,
so we need to look at responsibility
inside Mexico itself.
Now,
the truth is the mexican politicians
don't know how to advantaGe of this
fantastic opportunity to make Mexico
more modern and more competitive,
and does he know bad politics equals
bad,
right
results.
All of this means that Mexico has to
kneel in front of Donald Trump.
Well,
sesame,
not
Donald Trump,
threatens Mexico with high tariffs on
their products.
If they refuse to pay for the wall to be
specific,
trump's administration is threatened.
A 20 percent tariff increase for
starters weld.
This would be illegal.
There are rules in the world trade
organization that prevent this from
happening.
One of these is known as the most
favored nation,
which means that one member of the wto
cannot discriminate against another,
in fact,
to this means that the maximum tariff
would be limited to three percent in the
case that nafta were abolished.
This would be a tax for consumers and
american companies and wouldn't affect
the trade between the two nations,
but even if the u s with the approval of
congress were willing to ignore
international law,
Mexico has enough resources to fight and
try and stop this first at Mexico would
be able to take advantage of the
influence of the multinational
corporations operating in Mexico,
which could stand to lose billions of
dollars and this is not just the
influence of a few rich men were talking
about all of these companies,
workers and their shareholders as well
as millions of individual savers
throughout the United States and the
second reason,
well relations between Mexico and theu ,
s on just commercial immigration,
drug trafficking,
terrorism.
TheSe are just a few aspects of that
relationship.
If trump attacks economically,
Mexico could find back,
for example,
by letting the us drown in drugs and
immigration waves from countries all
across latin America.
The fact is that the u,
s and Mexico need each other more than
it seems,
and Mexico is not seen as weak of a
position as trump thinks.
Although the president is in Mexico is
unpredictable.
It does look like he understands this
and the message from his government is
clear.
Let's talk about nafta.
We can renegotiate this treaty,
but then all these other treaties,
so we're also going to be open to
negotiation.
It's like this is what we think's going
to happen here,
a visual politic,
and we'd love to know what you think.
Do you think Mexico should defend itself
tooth and nail even with the risk of
triggering a trade war with the United
States,
or do you think the nation should be
patient to let things go and look for a
solution elsewhere?
Let us know in the comments below.
We do read them and we tried to reply
when we can.
Don't forget that we put up brand new
videos every monday and thursday,
so do not forget to subscribe and as
always I'll see you in the next video.
I think I'm going to win the mexican
vogue.
Mexico,
Mexico.
We have a problem called Mexico.
Mexico's killing us.
Mexico is the disgusting Mexico.
They're killing us.
jeff alarm,
gray pedelec.
When I don't care if I mispronounce it
doesn't matter.